اقتحام قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيليه البلده
القديمه في نابلس حيث اكد الهلال الاحمر
الفلسطيني ان قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
اغتالت صباح اليوم ثلاثه فلسطينيين على
الاقل في عمليتها العسكريه التي نفذتها في
البلده القديمه من مدينه نابلس حسب
المصادر الفلسطينيه فان الشهداء تم انتشار
جثامينهم من داخل المنزل الذي حاصرته هذه
القوات واطلقت النيران على من فيها وكانت
اذاعه الجيش الاسرائيلي قد افادت انه تم
قتل عدد من المسلحين الذين تحصنوا داخل
احد المباني وقال الهلال الاحمر الفلسطيني
ان قوات الاحتلال منعت طواقمه من الوصول
الى المصابين والجرحى الذين تحاصرهم قوات
الاحتلال داخل البلده القديمه
قد اعلنت بلديه نابلس تاجيل بدء الدراسه
في كافه مدارس المدينه ومعاهدها بسبب
التوغل الاسرائيلي
معنا الان من رام الله مدير مكتب الجزيره
وليد العمري لكن قبل ذلك نشير الى ان هذه
الصور التي نشاهد الان والتقطت من نابلس
قبل قليل
هي لحظه انتشال جثامين الشهداء الثلاثه من
المبنى الذي حاصرته قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي واقتحمته وقاتلت ثلاثه
فلسطينيين
ما زلنا في انتظار معلومات اخرى عما يجري
لكن وليد العمري ربما يضعنا في صوره اخر
تحديث لهذه المعلومات وليد
نعم حتى الان المؤكد ان هناك ثلاثه شهداء
وهناك عددا من الجرحى بينهم طلبه في مدرسه
الفاطميه الذين اصيبوا بحالات اغماء جراء
اطلاق الغاز عليهم ما جرى في مدينه نابلس
ان قوات الاحتلال قوه مشتركه من وحدات
النخبه في الجيش والشرطه وحرس الحدود
والشباك كانت قد توغلت في قلب البلده
القديمه تحديدا حي الياسمين والفاطميه
وحاصرت البلده القديمه بالكامل بعد ان
احتل جنودها اسطح المنازل الجنود الذين
يتسترون بالزي المدني غالبا والذين يسمون
بالمستعربين وقامت بمحاصره منزل هناك
تحصنا في داخله مجموعه من المقاومين
الفلسطينيين كما يبدو بان سلطات الاحتلال
تشتبه بان بينهم منفذي الهجوم الذي وقع في
منطقه الحمراء قبل نحو ثلاثه اسابيع وقتلت
فيه ثلاثه مستوطنات انذاك وضع اطلقت
النيران وقعت اشتباكات لكن اطلقت النيران
مباشره على المنزل كانت قد منعت سيارات
الاسعاف التابعه للهلال الاحمر الفلسطيني
من ان تصل الى المناطق التي فيها مصابين
وبعد ان بدات هذه القوات باعاده انتشارها
او انسحابها في هذه اللحظات من البلده
القديمه وصل المواطنون الى المبنى او
المنزل الذي استهدفته قوات الاحتلال
فعثروا في داخله على ثلاثه من الشهداء حتى
هذه اللحظه لم تتضح هويتهم بالكامل لكن
المرجح ان بينهم على الاقل كما تروج قوات
الاحتلال من نفذوا العمليه في حينه هذه
العمليه تاتي في سياق عمليات متواصله
يراها الفلسطينيون انها حرب تشنها قوات
الاحتلال على الشعب الفلسطيني منذ نحو
العام والتي تطلق عليها في اطار الكاسر
الامواج كما اطلقت عليها من قبل والتي من
بدايه هذا العام بسقوط هذا العدد من
الشهداء قد ارتفع العدد الى اكثر من 105
شهداء في كافه ارجاء الضفه الغربيه معظمهم
في مدني ومخيمات جنين ونابلس وكذلك اريحا